hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein leckeres rezept
mit hefeteig ich mache ich mag hefeteig
ja ganz gern und machen auch wirklich
ziemlich oft es gibt wirklich viele
rezepte die man unbedingt mal
ausprobieren sollte
dazu gehört vor allem dieses hier ich
habe nämlich den hefeteig gefüllt mit
einer leckeren zitronen käsecreme und
hab da noch glauben mit rein gegeben das
ganze zu schnecken aufgerollt und dann
zu einem kranz gereiht also sieht
wirklich nicht nur hübsch aus sondern
schmeckt auch sehr lecker und ich stelle
jetzt zuerst mal den hefeteig er und
zeigt euch bossi zutaten für den
hefeteig brauche ich einen beruf frische
hefe oder zwei päckchen trockenhefe 80
den zucker 2 esslöffel warmes wasser
einen teelöffel salz und etwas vanille
extrakt 500 gramm mehl 200 milliliter
milch 1 81 gramm zerlassene butter so es
gebe ich jetzt wie immer die hefe und
eine rührschüssel und löse sie in etwas
wasser aus und da kommt jetzt noch der
zucker mit rein obwohl man fröhlich die
drei zutaten miteinander
gebe ich noch dass vanille extrakt mit
dazu einfach nur so ein bisschen was für
den geschmack und jetzt kann schon mal
die milch mit rein dann auch das ei und
etwas mehl und dann las ich das erstmal
ein bisschen verrühren
jetzt gebe ich immer mehr mieter zu es
gibt auch direkt die butter mit rein und
dann sollte ein schöner weißer teig
entstehen und den lass dir dann für
etwas sieben minuten kneten
falls der teig zu weich ist gibt er
einfach ein bisschen mehl mit rein da
kommt einfach immer darauf an wie groß
das war
der teig ist fertig wenn er nicht mehr
an den händen klebt ich nehme ich ihnen
heraus und kneten einmal noch so durch
und da kräht jetzt auch eben nicht an
der oberfläche
jetzt freu mich eine kugel daraus und
lasst den teig gleich nochmal aufgehen
dafür gebe ich ihnen jetzt wieder zurück
in die schüssel und wir gehen mit etwas
mehl decke ab und lass ihn für etwa 30
60 minuten aufgehen
der hefeteig ist jetzt gut aufgegangen
wie man hier sieht eine richtig tolle
kugel und jetzt habe ich hier vorne
schon die zutaten für die füllung ich
werde jetzt in hefeteig mit einer
zitronige füllung für und dann kommen
noch heidelberg mit rein
für die füllung brauche ich 300 gramm
tiefgekühlte heidelbeeren dann brauche
ich etwas lernen gehört das habe ich
selbst gemacht 30 g speisestärke und 250
km marke quark beim lehman-crash das
habe ich euch ja bereits schon gegeben
das rezept des verlinkt ich euch gerne
nochmal in der infobox und bei den high
die bayern ist es so wenn ihr natürlich
auch frische bekommt zur socken und
natürlich auch frische die bahn benutzen
aber so habe das eben immer griffbereit
wenn er sie im tiefkühlfach habt ich
pack das ganze gleich in meinem pizza
backblech und da kommt es noch ein back
at drüber und schreibe ich jetzt erstmal
hund zeigen kurzen trick und zwar falls
es einmal in der mitte dann nochmal
falten und nochmal falten als immer zur
geschlossenen spitze und wenn es geht
nochmal so und damit ihre richtige größe
jetzt gleich habt legte jetzt die spitze
direkt hier in die mitte jetzt könnte
einfach mit der schere hier außen herum
schneiden eben immer die richtige größe
als ihr könnt es theoretisch auch ganz
passend machen wir das jetzt genauso
groß wie das letztlich haben wollt müsse
weiter innen schneiden ich möchte ein
bisschen größer 85 effekten so gebe ich
den quark zur speisestärke hatte ich
früher mal ganz kurz damit die klümpchen
weg gehen
ja und dann darfst du gleich rühren
jetzt gebe ich da etwa 4 esslöffel lemon
card mit rein das gibt's natürlich auch
fertig zu kaufen
3 aber selbst gemacht schmeckt mir
natürlich besser und vor allen dingen
ist auch wirklich nicht schwierig das
herzustellen
durch die füllung erstmal zur seite
stellen und bestäubt die arbeitswelt mit
etwas mehl und rolle den teig jetzt groß
aus als rechteck groß
jetzt streiche ich die füllung da drauf
und wenn die füllung euch jetzt nicht
süß genug ist könnte sie gerne mal nach
süßen aber ich lasse es jetzt so denn
bei mir kommt ja später noch im bus
drauf und dann gleicht sich das wieder
ganz gut aus so auf der einen seite hier
lasse ich jetzt dann brand
jetzt stehe ich ja die blaubeeren darauf
könnte man natürlich auch himbeeren zum
beispiel nehmen die passen auch gut
unternimmt jetzt so viele wie ihr
möchtet und gerne könnt ihr auch ein
paar später für den guss aufheben
und wenn eure finger jetzt auch blau
geworden sind von den blau werden so wie
hier nehmen wir einfach eine
ausgedrückte zitrone mittel die reste
verwerten und tauchte jetzt die finger
hier ein
und dann werden die wieder weiß
jetzt hole ich den teig von dieser seite
her auf und da unten habe ich eine
stelle frei gelassen damit er die
füllung da jetzt nicht raus bild und die
rolle auch gut zusammenklebt
und zum schneiden dem jetzt entweder ein
messer oder nimmt einen faden und zwar
könnt ihr dann ohne messer schneiden
legt er den faden außen herum wenn jetzt
keinen so festen faden habt geht zum
beispiel auch zahnseide ganz gut und
dann schneide ich jetzt hier diese
schnecken ab und die haben dann so eine
breite von zwei zentimetern etwa mit den
knoten reinmacht geht's übrigens besser
abschneiden
jetzt setzte sich die leicht versetzt in
einem trans o flex
und so gebe ich jetzt diesen heidelberg
kam es in den kalten backofen stellen
dann auf 190 grad
und dann wird der graben etwa 30 bis 35
minuten gebacken bis der teig schön
goldbraun ist und mit dem aufwärmen des
ofens kann jetzt auch der hefeteig
nochmal aufgehen der blogwerk kriegen
ist jetzt aus dem ofen herauskriegen
kranken blau erkrankt und die farben
sind natürlich richtig genial also diese
blaue band sind wirklich wunderschön aus
wie gemalt
ich finde irgendwie weiß es gibt keine
andere frucht oder keinen anderen fische
diese tolle farbe ist einfach auf jeden
fall könnt ihr den jetzt so lassen wie
mit puderzucker bestreuen
oder so wie ich das jetzt mache mit
einem guss bestreichen und zwar habe ich
hier vorne zwei zutaten ich habe einmal
40 gramm puderzucker und etwas milch
einfach so etwa zwei bis drei esslöffel
milch zur butter zucker dem schneebesen
jetzt wollen wir einfach so lange bis
die zutaten sich verbunden haben
und man könnte jetzt natürlich auch
etwas zitronensaft nehmen aber dann ist
das richtig gefahr dass etwas zu sauer
wird also ich mag es eigentlich ganz
gerne mal zu ehrlich so ganz sauer
deswegen
milch statt zitrone
jetzt könnte das entweder mit einem
silikon busen drauf streichen oder ihr
macht das jetzt so wie ich einfach mit
dem löffel ein bisschen quer beet drüber
sieht nämlich auch ganz hübsch aus
jetzt sind wir fertig von mira hat ihre
auch schon fertig sie durfte nämlich der
selben tag stück bekommt man durfte ist
ein anfang und das ende haben und hat
daraus erstellen daraus gemacht kleine
schnecken und herzchen geld das macht
doch gar nicht schmeckt auf jedenfalls
sehr gut mit dem rad direkt mal
probieren
ich freue mich schon auf die
verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen gibt
es aus zählte also ich finde die farbe
ist wirklich genial angesagt mal
wirklich öfter was mit lauten ja super
hier bekommst du beides von uns freuen
kann schlägt wieder zu und diese
käsecreme also der quargel drin der
sorgt dafür dass es noch mal richtig
saftig werden jetzt 1 probierte auch
gleich richtig sagt ja ganz ehrlich ich
probier zu mir ist ja bin aber ehrlich
du bist ehrlich und zwar ist das ehrlich
lecker denn viel besser als mainz oder
ja ja sie zusammen 81 schmeckt besser
ja auf jeden fall die sind wirklich sehr
saftig und ich finde sie richtig hübsch
aus also mir gefällt es sehr gut wenn
ihr das rezept nach machen wollt geht
auf 6 - blog.de da steht es noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
ganz viel spaß beim nachhaken
lecker der mannschaft darf ich auch noch
verlieren von dir du bist ein schatz
sag einfach jetzt und dann klappe küste
und jetzt kinder macht so und jetzt und
dann nimmst du so hoch okay achtung
jetzt dass es noch so jetzt satt und
jetzt nein
und jetzt